Guten Abend, guten Tag, ich bin hier die zuständige Ärztin für Sie und würde gerne ein Aufnahmegespräch führen. Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Kerstin Meyerhoff.
Kerstin Meyerhoff.
Meyerhoff.
M-E-Y-E-R
irregular, billing, doppel F
ek 추가
und dann Hunger, H-U-Doppel-F
Doppel F
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vorname auch buchstabieren?
Ja, Kerstin
K-E-R-S-T-I-N
Kerstin
Um Sie herzugehen, würde ich nochmal buchstabieren?
K E R S T I N
Richtig!
Und Nachname M A Y E
M E Y
M E, I wie I da
M E wie Emil
Emil, okay, vielen Dank!
M E wie Emil, Y E wie Emil
R wie Richard
H wie...
Ist egal!
Hans
O und Doppel F
Sehr gut!
Ja, vielen Dank!
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 38
Okay, 38. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 8.3.88
Mhm, 88. Okay, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin so 1,68
Okay, wissen Sie wie viel Sie wiegen?
So ungefähr 75 Kilo
75. Okay, vielen Dank für diese Informationen!
Frau Meyeroff, was wird Sie heute zu uns?
Ja, also Sie sehen ja mein Mann ist bei mir
und es war ganz merkwürdig, wir haben am Abend zusammen im Wohnzimmer gesessen
und mit einem Mal habe ich ganz komisch angefangen mit den Armen und Beinen zu zucken
ich konnte das überhaupt nicht mehr kontrollieren
und ja, das war natürlich unheimlich
und ja, ich habe das schon ein bisschen gemerkt, seit drei Tagen war ich total kribbelig und nervös und unruhig
aber jetzt diese Geschichte da, ich konnte das wirklich nicht kontrollieren
mit einem Mal haben die Arme und Beine gemacht, was sie wollten
und ja, er hat mich ins Auto gesetzt und ist mit mir sofort hierher gekommen
Okay, Sie haben gut gemacht
Die beiden Arme oder Beine oder linke Seite, rechte Seite?
Nee, beide Arme und Beine
Oh, alle? Okay
Seit wann? Seit drei Tagen?
Nein, das war jetzt heute einmalig
Seit drei Tagen fühle ich mich nervös
Aha, okay
Das habe ich im Nachhinein halb gesagt, ja Mensch, das waren auch hektische Tage jetzt
und ich bin nie so richtig zur Ruhe gekommen
Okay, ja ich verstehe
Haben Sie etwas ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Ich meine seit drei Tagen oder heute Morgen, alles in Ihrem Leben?
Ja, wir haben gestern Abend in meiner Firma ein bisschen Party gefeiert
und haben da auch ziemlich viel Alkohol getrunken, ja schon
und wenn ich jetzt so überlege ungefähr
ja, als wir uns hingesetzt haben im Wohnzimmer
da habe ich so zum Fenster rausgeguckt und habe mir einmal gemerkt, das Licht stört mich total
und dann habe ich auch gemerkt, dass ich so ein bisschen Kopfschmerzen habe
und hatte also zwischendurch das Gefühl, dass ich so blitze sehe
als ob jemand so mit Blitzlicht fotografiert
Waren Sie unmächtig?
Nein
Okay, hatten Sie gleichzeitig Herzrasen, Atemnot?
Atemnot ist mir nicht aufgefallen, aber ich hatte das Gefühl, dass das Herz wirklich doll klopft, ja
Okay
Haben Sie irgendwelche englischen Bechwerde oder nur Sie haben?
Zum Glück nur ich, ja
Okay
Fühlen Sie sich fieberig oder hatten Sie Fieber?
Nein
Ich weiß
Hatten Sie Seher oder Hörstörungen?
Hörstörungen nicht, aber Sehstörungen habe ich ja gesagt, dass ich so Lichtblitze gesehen habe
und dass ich auch so empfindlich war auf Licht, ja
dass ich mich geblendet gefühlt habe
Und auch Hörstörungen haben Sie gesehen?
Nein, Hörstörungen nicht
Nein
Okay
Nein, nein
Hatten Sie Muskelschwäche oder Lähmungserscheinungen gemerkt?
Nein, nein, nein
Aber jetzt Ihre...
Jetzt kann ich alles wieder koordinieren
Erwägung, okay
Okay, ich verstehe
38, okay
Okay
Ist Ihnen übel?
Jetzt fühle ich mich wirklich ein bisschen schlecht
und habe auch so das Gefühl, dass ich total K.o. bin, dass ich total müde bin
Früher hatten Sie diese ähnliche Beschwerden?
Nein
Erstmalig, ja Sie haben gesagt, Entschuldigung
Ich habe so etwas noch nie erlebt
Entschuldigung, Herr Meyhoff
Haben Sie Erbruch?
Nein, also nein, habe ich nicht
Was für Probleme oder Stuhlgangsprobleme haben Sie?
Also ich habe regelmäßig immer ein bisschen Probleme mit dem Darm
Also man sagt, ich habe bereits Darm
und wenn ich da, ja, wenn ich da Schwierigkeiten habe, dann nehme ich halt Imodium
und dann ist es erstmal wieder Ruhe
Aber jetzt, in diesem Zusammenhang hatte ich keine Probleme
Okay
Was haben Sie angenommen? Entschuldigung, Medikament oder?
Ja, wenn ich bei Darmbeschwerden, wenn ich Durchfall hatte, dann habe ich immer Imodium genommen
Imodium heißt es
Imodium, ist das ein Tablet von arztlichen Rezepten?
Ja, die hatten mir der Arzt geschrieben
Okay, danke
Okay, ich verstehe
In letzter Zeit haben Sie ungewollt Gewicht ab oder zugenommen?
Also, ich glaube, das Gewicht ist immer gleich
Man merkt das ja an den Kleidern oder so, ob es irgendwo rutscht oder kneift
Aber ich habe, mein Gewicht ist stabil
Okay, und ich würde gerne wissen, schlafen Sie seit drei Tagen gut oder?
Ja, also letzte Nacht habe ich halt nicht viel geschlafen und ein bisschen viel Alkohol getrunken
Aber sonst?
Ja, manchmal bin ich schon auch ein bisschen genervt und dann schlafe ich auch nicht so gut
Wie ist Ihr Essen, Ihr Appetit? Ist gut?
Ja, würde ich schon sagen, wenn ich dazu komme, dann esse ich schon auch regelmäßig
und ich muss ja auch für mein Kind immer kochen
Also, essen wir schon auch regelmäßig und auch gut, würde ich sagen
Besuchen Sie Ihren Frauenarzt regelmäßig? Gibt es?
Da gibt es keine Probleme, ich gehe halt regelmäßig zur Kontrolle einmal im Jahr
Wann war die letzte Periode?
Das ist jetzt zweieinhalb Wochen her
Zwei und? Okay
Bei Ihnen irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen bemerkt?
Wie gesagt, dieser Reizdarm, das hat mir mein Haushalt mal gesagt
Dann habe ich ja, das ist keine chronische Erkrankung, aber ich habe halt so ein Exzem hinter dem Ohr
Also so eine Hautreaktion und da muss ich immer irgendwelche Salbe auftragen
Okay, seit wann Ihr Reizdarmsyndrom festgestellt?
Das kann ich Ihnen gar nicht sagen, das ist schon lange, eigentlich seit ich erwachsen bin
Okay, Hautausschlag, okay
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente außer im Modium?
Ja, eben diese Kopfsalbe, die heißt Lugal und die mache ich mir dann dahinter die Ohren, wo die Haut so verändert ist
Und Sie hören ja, ich habe so eine ganz heißere Stimme
Ich habe Stimmbandknötchen und deswegen muss ich manchmal, wenn das ganz schlimm wird und ich ganz heißer bin
Dann nehme ich so Neoangin, das sind so Lutschtabletten, damit ich mich so heißer und nicht...
Könnten Sie bitte nochmal sagen, Entschuldigung?
Neoangin
Neoangin heißt das
Neoangin, wie Angina
Angina, okay
Neoangin, okay
Neoangin heißt das Medikament
Okay, verstehe
Und könnten Sie bitte Ihre Salbe, Name?
Die heißt Lugal Salbe
Lugal, ja, Lugal
Lügal, okay
Lügal, okay, danke
Und sind Sie schon operiert worden?
Ne, ich habe noch nie eine Operation gehabt, stimmt ja
Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Ja, also ich muss immer sehr auf Sauberkeit achten
Ich habe eine Hausstaubmildenallergie, also muss ich ständig die Betten neu beziehen und absaugen und so
Und dann habe ich ja, das ist so gastronomisch manchmal ein bisschen traurig
Ich habe eine Allergie gegen Meeresfrüchte
Und deswegen kann ich also nie Krabben oder Fisch oder Muscheln oder irgendwie sowas, was andere sehr lecker finden, kann ich nie mitessen
Wie reagiert es darauf?
Essen oder Saubstoff?
Ja, also da kriege ich wirklich so rote Flecken im Gesicht und merke, dass die Zunge taub wird und so, das ist sehr unangenehm
Rote Flecken im Gesicht, okay
Und Taubheitsgefühl im Mund oder okay, Unmund, Gehfühl, okay
Vielen Dank für diese richtige Information
Und Unverträglichkeit hatten Sie?
Soll ich...
Soll ich wissen?
Haben Sie Unverträglichkeit?
Also wie gesagt Meeresfrüchte darf ich nicht essen und sonst habe ich aber nichts, was ich an mich nicht vertragen kann
Okay und wie ist Ihr Nikotinkonsum?
Ja, also ich rauche, aber ich rauche wirklich nicht viel, ich rauche nur so eine halbe Packung am Tag
Halbe Packung, okay
Sind Zigaretten täglich seit wann?
Seit ich 18 bin
18, ja das ist nicht wenig, ja
Und wie ist Ihr Alkoholkonsum?
Na, ich trinke eigentlich nicht regelmäßig so viel Alkohol, also schon wenn es was zu feiern gibt oder wenn es mal ein sehr gutes Essen gibt oder so
Aber ja gestern Abend da war so tolle Stimmung und wir hatten was zu feiern und das war richtig schön
Und dann schmeckten die Cocktails so gut und da habe ich ein bisschen viel zu fassen gehabt
Aber normalerweise am Wochenende trinken Sie oder täglich?
Ja, täglich nicht, aber vielleicht schon so 3 mal in der Woche oder so
Okay, 3 mal
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Ja, früher mal, früher mal habe ich mal Haschisch geraucht, ja, aber das war nicht
Was heißt Früh Hasch?
Na ja, so mit 19, 20 habe ich das mal probiert und dann habe ich aber schnell wieder die Finger davon gelassen
Ja, okay, okay
Ich habe ein paar Fragen über Ihre Familiengeschichte
Leiden Sie irgendwelche chronischen Krankheiten? Ihre Vater, Ihre Mutter meine ich
Ach so, chronische Krankheiten haben die?
Zum Beispiel Blutzucker
Nee, also das haben die alles nicht, die sind ja auch noch relativ jung
Also mein Vater, der war jetzt vor 4 Monaten in der Klinik, der hatte irgendwie an den Augen eine
Hornhautentzündung und musste ein Auge operiert werden und das war wohl ein bisschen unangenehm, aber das ist ja keine chronische Erkrankung
Das ist gut
Und meine Mutter, die hat sich vor ein paar Jahren das Handgelenk gebrochen und es ist nie wieder gut geworden
Die hat also permanent Schmerzen, die hat so ein, das heißt Morbus Sudek
Die hat also immer Beschwerden mit diesem Handgelenk und die ist richtig eingeschränkt damit, aber auch das ist ja keine chronische Erkrankung in dem Sinne
Welche Hand?
Äh, rechte Hand
Insofern ist sie auch wirklich ein bisschen eingeschränkt
Rechter Hand, ist die Rechter Hand da?
Na ja, das schränkt sie schon sehr ein
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich war Einzelkind
Okay, was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ja, ich bin selbstständig, ich habe einen kleinen Poppelshop in der Nähe, in der Stadt hier und da mache ich halt Drucksachen und erledige so kleine Aufträge, verkaufe nebenher so ein bisschen Papeterie und ja
Was verkaufen Sie?
Ja, so Briefpapier und Schulzutaten, was ich gleich dich durchlebe
Wie Teleöken oder?
Teleöken
Telekom?
Oder was?
Teleöken
Äh
Ich weiß nicht, was Sie meinen
Okay, vielleicht erinnere ich mich falsch daran
So Schreibwaren
Teleöken
Nein, okay, vielleicht erinnere ich mich falsch
Ich wüsste nicht, was Sie meinen
Eine kleine Geschäft in Dorf
Ein Kopyshop
Ein paar Hefts verkaufen
Papier, Schulhefte, Schreibpapier, Briefumschläge und sowas
Ja, okay
Und haben Sie sich Stress bei Ihrer Arbeit?
Ja, manchmal ist es natürlich schon stressig, ja gerade wenn mal eine Maschine kaputt ist, dann hat man gerade einen Auftrag und dann geht ein Kopierer kaputt oder was weiß ich
Der Toner ist alle und man muss wieder alles nochmal von vorne anfangen
Also da gibt es schon auch mal Stress und die Kunden sind auch nicht immer nett
Okay, wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Ein Kind habe ich
Okay
Frau Meyerhoff, jetzt bin ich fertig mit meinen Fragen
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder wichtiges mit mir mitteilen?
Ich habe Ihnen jetzt so viel erzählt und ich bin ja auch ein bisschen schlapp, muss ich sagen und so ein bisschen müde
Ich wüsste gar nicht mehr, was ich Ihnen alles schon gesagt habe
Aber ich denke mal Sie haben bestimmt alles wichtige erfahren von mir
Ja, Frau Meyerhoff, aufgrund Ihrer Beschwerden, hochdosiertes Alkoholkonsum und Herzklopfen, nervöse Tät, kribbelnde Gefühle
Und ich habe einen Verdacht auf vielleicht Alkoholintoxikation
So viel war das nicht
Oder Vitamin B12-Pandel vielleicht oder
Was kann man denn jetzt machen um das aufzusuchen?
Neurologische Störungen, ja, ich würde gerne Sie zuerst körperlich untersuchen
Körperlich untersuchen?
Körperlich untersuchen, etwas Blut abnehmen
Und soll ich vielleicht eine neurologische Konsüle anfordern?
Natürlich gebe ich Bescheid mit meinem Oberarzt und danach sprechen wir mit Ihnen Schritt für Schritt
Ja, das ist gut
Sie sollen zuerst Stationäre aufnehmen
Ich muss da bleiben, jetzt geht es mir doch wieder gut
Nicht genau, Entschuldigung, nach dem Ergebnis vorliegen, sprechen wir nochmal
Nachdem wir Ergebnisse vorliegen, ok, dann hoffe ich mal, dass da nichts Schlimmes rauskommt
Dankeschön
Ok, möchte jemand noch zusätzliche Fragen stellen?
Ich konnte nicht genau folgen, hätten Sie für ein Lehrbeschwerden gefolgt?
Noch nie, war erstmalig
Erstmalig?
Wie lange dauert das Ereignis?
Das muss ganz kurz gewesen sein, ich kann das selber überhaupt nicht einschätzen
Aber ich denke, mir kam das natürlich lange vor
Aber ich glaube, das war nur eine Minute oder zwei Minuten oder so, ich glaube das war nicht viel länger
Während des Ereignisses oder des Anfalls hatten Sie ungewöhnlich Wasser lassen?
Sie meinen, ob ich mich eingenässt habe, meinen Sie?
Dass ich unkontrolliert Wasser lassen habe?
Nein, ich habe mich nicht eingenässt, das ist nicht passiert
Hat jemand noch andere Fragen?
Ja, tatsächlich als kleines Kind, als einjähriges Kind, das hat meine Mutter mir erzählt
Dass ich da mal mit Blaulicht ins Krankenhaus gekommen bin, weil ich einen Fieberkrampf hatte, das stimmt ja
Und letzte Frage, hatten Sie in letzter Zeit Kopfverletzungen?
Kopfverletzung? Nee
Also, dass ich irgendwo einen Fahrradunfall hatte oder so? Nee, ich habe mir oder nicht mal irgendwie eine Beule gestoßen
Danke
Ich habe eine Frage stellen, in den nächsten Tagen hatten Sie eine Kurse an Seidbenommenheit oder eine Bewusstlosheit?
Nein, Bewusstlosheit nicht, was ich gemerkt habe, dass ich seit ein paar Tagen so krimmelig war
Aber ich habe halt gedacht, das hängt damit zusammen, dass wir da diese Party halt vor hatten
Und dass da viel zu organisieren war
Und ich bin da nicht drauf gekommen, dass das was mit meiner Gesundheit zu tun hat
Danke schön
Frau Dr. Ipek, sind Sie soweit?
Ja, ich versuche
Ja, sehr gern
Meine zweite Versuche in diesem neurologischen Fall
Darf ich Ihnen vorstellen?
Ja, natürlich
Ganz schwer
Aber könnte sein, natürlich
Da gibt es ein
Auslöser, vielleicht hochdosiert Alkohol trinken oder
Machen Sie mal Ihre Fallbesprechungen
Okay
Aufgenommen wurde Kerstin Meyerhoff
Sie ist 38 Jahre alt, geboren am 8.3.1988
Sie ist 1,68 Meter groß und wiegt 75 Kilo
Sie kam heute zu uns wegen Kopfschmerzen, Blitzen von den Augen und Zuckungen
Seit drei Tagen berichtet mit...
Was für Zuckungen hat sie?
Zuckungen kann ich sagen
Zuckungen? Aber wo hat sie Zuckungen?
In beiden Händen und beiden Beinen
Okay
Seit drei Tagen berichtet sie, dass Nervosität und kribende Parastese haben
Und begleitend sind, kann ich Tachycardi sagen oder?
Fragen nach Herzras, Brustschmerzen, Luftnot, würden Ferneit
Wurden Ferneit?
Und Vegetative Anamnese erwähnt sie Übelkeit, sogenannten Neusea, Diarrhe
Und...
Diarrhe jetzt, akut?
Nein, jetzt nicht, Entschuldigung
Und Beschwerden bedingte Schlafstörungen
An Vorerkrankungen leidet sie an Reisdarm-Syndrom und Hautausschlag oder Exanthemm hinter den Ohren
Dagegen nimmt sie bei Bedarf Imodium gegen Reisdarm-Syndrom und Lügelsalbe hinter den Ohren
Manchmal leitet sie unter auch Kopfschmerzen
Dagegen nimmt sie Neoangine
Kopfschmerzen, okay
Oder habe ich falsch verstanden
Okay, sprechen wir gleich
Ist Ihnen keine Operation bekannt?
Ist dir keine Operation bekannt, ja?
An allergischer Anamnese sind mehrere Frühstücke und Sauerstoff bekannt
Sie reagiert darauf
Es gibt rote Flecken im Gesicht
Und mehrere Früchte, Fisch, Muschen reagieren darauf, dass sie Taupeitsgefühl haben
Imodium
Entschuldigung
An einer Anamnese berichtet sie seit ungefähr mit 18 Jahren täglich 10 Zigaretten
Also seit 18 Jahren
Oh, seit 18 Jahren, ja
Entschuldigung, seit 18 Jahren
Und Alkohol
Nein, ich habe falsch gesagt
Seit dem 18. Lebensjahr
Also seit 20 Jahren
Seit dem 18. Lebensjahr bzw. seit 20 Jahren braucht sie eine halbe Packung
Lebensjahr, okay
Ich notiere, Entschuldigung
Okay, danke schön
Und Alkoholkonsum ist wochenlich 3 oder 2 Mal in der Woche
Aber beim Feiern manchmal trinkt sie mehr als uns
Und Drogenkonsum würde verneint, kann ich sagen, oder?
Naja, ganz nicht
Okay, Drogenkonsum, sie hat mit 19 und 20 Jahren Drogen konsumiert
Aber was für welche?
Haschisch
Haschisch, ja
Also joint geraucht
Joint, ja
Das ist ja, ja
Es gab auch bei der Familie ergab sich Augenhornhaut
Was heißt das?
Augenhornhaut, Hornhaut
Retina ist das oder? Ich habe das vergessen
Hornhaut, Korna, Bildhaut, Konjunktiva
Die Beide, Konjunktiva
Nee, warten Sie, ich muss selber gucken
Die Hornhaut heißt
Hornhaut
Bei der Familienanamnese ergab sich Keratitis bei Vater
Und handgelenk gebrochener bei der Mutter bekannt
Ja
Sie ist selbstständig arbeitend
Sie arbeitet selbstständig
Sie arbeitet selbstständig und wohnt mit ihrem Ehemann
Und sie hat ein Kind, sie ist gesund
Ja
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf epileptische Anfalle
Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit der Patientin?
Ich würde gerne neurologisches Konsül anfordern
Was machen Sie selber mit der Patientin?
Ich würde gerne körperliche Untersuchungen
Worauf achten Sie dabei?
Und besonders neurologische Untersuchungen, Vitalparameter natürlich
Zuerst muss ich überwachen
Und neurologische Untersuchungen, reflexive, sensibile und motorentatent
Reflexe, Sensibilität und Motorik
Natürlich auch EKG
Sie berichtet über Herzklopfen
Ich denke auch, Echo ist auch wichtig
Und bei der Neurologie vielleicht EMG
EMG für Muskeln und EEG für Neurologie
Die Differentialdiagnose kommt vielleicht in MS
Sie ist 38 Jahre alt
Und vielleicht auch Cerebrovascular Krankheit
Ja, ich habe noch eine Differentialdiagnose mit auf dem Zettel
Tier, oder?
Ja, die habe ich auch mit dabei
Und auch Migräne
Wobei das eigentlich... na gut, okay
Und Worst Case natürlich ein Hirntumor
Ja, beidseitig
Gut, was machen Sie weiterhin diagnostisch?
Weiterhin diagnostisch
Ich würde gerne Labountersuchungen durchführen
Entzündungsparameter
Ich habe nicht gefragt, vielleicht waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Urlaub oder so
Ich habe leider nicht gefragt das
Blutbildentzündungsparameter
B12-Vitaminparameter
Und Gerümmungsparameter natürlich
Und MRT wegen Gehirntumor auszuschließen
Sie ist eine ganz junge Frau
Vielleicht andere Epilepsie-EEG habe ich gesagt
Was erwarten Sie denn jetzt im Augenblick von der neurologischen Untersuchung und auch vom EEG?
Was meinen Sie, wird man da finden?
Ja, das ist ja nicht einfach für mich
Ich sage Ihnen das jetzt einfach
Das ist auch für den Spezialisten nicht einfach
Denn wenn das tatsächlich ein epileptischer Anfall war
Nach dem Anfall gibt es keine Nachweise darüber
Das EEG ist danach wieder unauffällig
Und auch die neurologischen Sachen sind wieder normal nach dem Anfall
Insofern kann man nur die brutale Methode machen
Dass man sagt, man versucht nochmal einen Anfall auszulösen
Oder man sagt, man muss warten
Ob es nochmal wieder kommt
Manchmal macht man eben auch diese Geschichte
Dass man sagt, alles andere haben wir ausgeschlossen
Es war vermutlich das gut
Haben Sie eine Idee, was man dann weiterhin macht?
Was sollte die Patientin bezüglich ihrer Lebensgewohnheiten machen?
Ich würde eine Alkoholkehren empfehlen
Auch die Cotin ist ganz gefährlich
Sie ist ein bisschen übergewicht...
Nein, nein, Entschuldigung
Ja, in der Grenze vielleicht
Und Stress ausreduzieren
Das ist ganz wichtig
Sie ist zufrieden mit der Arbeit
Aber vielleicht zu viel Arbeit
Und ich habe noch zwei Sachen, die um die Ecke mit Stress zu tun haben
Einmal, weil das riskant ist, sie soll nicht Auto fahren
Wenn man selber am Steuer sitzt und man kriegt so einen Anfall, ist eher schlecht
Deswegen soll man ein halbes Jahr lang vorsichtig sein
Nicht selber Auto fahren
Und sie soll auch auf regelmäßigen Schlaf achten
Also keinen Schlafentzug in dieser Zeit
Um nicht was zu provozieren
Gut, dann bin ich mal gespannt, was bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt
Danke
Halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden über die Ergebnisse
Und dann gucken wir uns die Patientin nachher mal zusammen an
Sehr schön, Frau Dr. Ipek
Danke
Ja, wir haben ja so ein bisschen zusammengearbeitet
Was ich eine wichtige Frage fand
Da gibt es ja ganz offenbar einen Zusammenhang
Mit dem kindlichen Fieberkrämpfen und der Epilepsie
Und das ist tatsächlich ja hier benannt
Haben Sie aber nicht nachgefragt
Und Sie haben auch nicht nach weiteren Ereignissen im Lebenslauf gefragt
Also in der Vorerkrankung
Deswegen ist das gar nicht gekommen
Ja, tatsächlich ist es so, dass das EEG
Nach dem Anfall keine Auffälligkeiten zeigt
Ja, dann ist alles wieder gut
Man müsste praktisch den Augenblick erwischen
Und ja, das macht das ja so ein bisschen gespenstisch
Dass die Leute mit so einer tickenden Bombe irgendwo leben
Dass sie wissen, es könnte jederzeit losgehen
Aber ich weiß es vorher nicht
Ja gut, sie hat diese Nervosität vorher geschildert
Und was glaube ich auch so eine gewisse Aura ist im Vorfeld
Ist diese Lichtempfindlichkeit und Nervosität
Große Tipps für diese
Ja, und natürlich haben Sie genau recht, dass diese Patientin
Noxenkonsum auf alle Fälle runterfahren muss
Und es gibt Medikamente Antikonvulsiva
Die würde man aber nur einsetzen, wenn tatsächlich ein zweiter Anfall auftritt
Dann könnte man von möglicherweise einer manifesten Epilepsie sprechen
Aber so genau, was Dr. Puppi vorhin gesagt hat
Es ist ein epileptischer Anfall, der möglicherweise nie wieder auftaucht
Er war ja auch nicht so extrem
Wir haben diese berühmte Beschreibung Granmal
Wo die Leute eben tatsächlich
Ohnmächtig werden, denen fehlt richtig die Zeit
Wo sie sich auf die Zunge beißen
Und wo sie auch diese Schaumbildung vor dem Mund haben
Und sowas ja für die Umwelt immer hoch dramatisch ist
Oder Eingenessen
Genau, da hat ja auch jemand gemacht
Und insofern war das vielleicht so ein Schuss vor den Bug
Dass sie jetzt erst mal gesagt hat
Oder gemerkt hat, ich muss vorsichtig sein
Aber wenn sie Glück hat, kriegt sie halt keinen zweiten Anfall
Ja, ich fand es zwar wieder spannend
Auch wenn es für sie ein bisschen schwierig war
Sprachlich sag ich Ihnen mal
Fand ich den
In einem Näseteil wieder deutlich besser
Das muss ich noch mal gucken
Ich hab mir noch was aufgeschrieben
Genau, was ich wichtig finde in diesem Zusammenhang
Dass die in Begleitung ihres Ehemanns gekommen ist
Und dass der sie gebracht hat
Und dass der praktisch bestätigt hat, was sie sagt, diese Zukunft
Das ist ja ein wichtiger Punkt
Dass sie das nicht nur glaubt, sie hat gezuckt
Sondern der Mann hat es gesehen
Und dann hat er sie schnell in die Klinik gebracht
Dann meine ich, dieses Taubheitsgefühl in den Händen
Hätte ich nicht gesagt
Genau, und wichtig
Sie haben gesagt
Zuckung in den Händen und in den Beinen
In den Armen und in den Beinen
Also nicht nur in den Händen
Sondern in allen vier Extremitäten
Ja, gut
Das war das
Augenblick
Die Kopfschmerzen haben Sie glaube ich erwähnt
Die Übelkeit und die Müdigkeit
Also Fatigue hinterher
Genau, wo ich nicht so einig bin
Sie haben gesagt
Sie hat eine
In der Vegetativanamnese hat sie eine Schlafstörung
Also sie schläft nicht gut
Und dann leidet sie unter der Leidenschaft
Und dann leidet sie unter Diarrhoelen
Das würde ich zu den Vorerkrankungen zählen
Weil sie einen diagnostizierten Reizdarm hat
Und dann eben diese Dermatitis hinter dem Ohr
Und ja, dann kam ja tatsächlich durch ihren Kollegen noch
Die Nachfrage nach dem Fieberkrampf
Ja, gut
Also
Eine Sache
Ja, was ich nicht elegant fand
Also machen Sie ruhig so einen klaren Absatz
Dass Sie sagen
In der Familienanamnese gab die Patientin das
Also eigentlich keine klassische Vorerkrankung
Im Sinne von
Haben wir alle in der Familie hohen Blutdruck, Diabetes
Aber genau, was Sie nicht erzählt haben
Die Mutter hat einen Zustand der Handgelenksfraktur
Aber was sie jetzt hat
Ist ein Morbus Sudeck
Das ist diese ganz wahnsinnig schmerzhafte Geschichte
Wo zwischendurch
Also wirklich völlig immobil sind die Leute
Das heißt auch
Ich weiß nicht wie das übersetzt wird
CRPS
Vielleicht gibt es in der allgemeinen Formulierung
Noch eine andere Bezeichnung dafür
Weiß das jemand von den Kollegen zufällig
Dass er uns da mal eben helfen kann
Schau ich mal eben
Ihr habt jetzt geschrieben
Ah, okay
Also das gibt es bei Ihnen auch
Warum schreibe ich das auch noch falsch
Morbus Sudeck Hand
Genau, wahnsinnige Schwellungen
Schmerzhafte entzündliche Erkrankungen
Nachverletzungen oder Operationen
Genau
Ja, abgekürzt CRPS
Also das ist
Eine scheußliche Geschichte
Und damit ist die Mutter richtig eingeschränkt
Das nur als Ergänzung zur Familienanamnese
Ja, sozialanamnestisch ist sie eben verheiratet
Hat ein Kind
Und ist selbstständig
Hat dementsprechend ein bisschen Stress
Ich weiß nicht, haben Sie die Stimmbandknöle
Ach ja, genau
Da haben Sie Kopfschmerzen gesagt
Die Patientin hat gesagt
Sie hat Stimmbandknötchen
Neoangin ist so eine Blutstablette
Die den ganzen Schleimhautbereich im Mund total betäubt
Echt fies schmeckt
Ja, ich weiß, ich habe das auch mal früher gegen Halsschmerzen bekommen
Und damit hat sie eine Stimmstörung
Und da hat sie halt gesagt, dass sie diese Neoangine nimmt dagegen
Aber nicht gegen Kopfschmerzen
Ja, ich weiß nicht, wie sie da drauf gekommen sind
Das ist kein Kopfschmerzmittel
Gut
Dann, was haben wir noch gehabt?
Neurolog ist natürlich sehr clever zu sagen
Ich hole die Neurologen dazu
Da muss man die neurologische Untersuchung nicht selber machen
Das ist schon sehr elegant
Aber auf alle Fälle würde man natürlich jetzt die klassischen Reflexe checken
Kniescheibenreflex und was weiß ich
Die Hautsensibilität
Und vielleicht auch die Popillenreflexe
Dass man guckt, ob die Popillen wieder reagieren
Das wäre sicherlich noch etwas, was man mit eigenen Bordmitteln machen kann
Gut
Und dann, also im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch waren sie vielleicht auch wegen der Unterbrechung
Vielleicht auch, weil sie mit der Diagnose eigentlich gar nicht so sympathisiert haben am Anfang
Waren sie nicht so gut wie bei der Anamnese
Anamnese fand ich eigentlich ziemlich konsequent
Da haben sie dann, wenn sie mal gemerkt haben, dass die Patientin so ein bisschen ungeduldig war
Weil sie was gefragt haben, was sie schon mal vorher erzählt hat
Ja, ich weiß, stimmt, haben sie ja gesagt
Da sind sie immer drauf eingegangen
Sie waren sehr freundlich und sehr geduldig mit der Patientin
Aber dann im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch war es einfach von den Formulierungen her manchmal
Ja, nicht mehr so souverän und nicht mehr so sicher
Und da kamen dann auch manchmal so Grammatikfehler mit rein, die nicht verheerend sind
Aber wo man dann merkt, dass sie nicht mehr so auf sicherem Terrain sind
Und das ist, glaube ich, immer diese Schwierigkeit im Arzt-Patient-Gespräch
sind sie derjenige, der das Konzept in der Hand hat
Sie wissen, was sie fragen wollen
Und dann ziehen sie ihren Fragenkatalog durch
Und der Patient kann dann gucken, dass er antwortet
Und sie können das entsprechend verarbeiten
Aber wenn sie dann nachher im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch selber eine Situation schildern sollen
dann wird es einfach schwieriger
Und da denke ich immer, es ist sicherer, sich auf kurze präzise Sätze zu einigen
als dann irgendwie so eine ganz lange Geschichte zu machen
und es zu kompliziert zu machen
Und versuchen sie einfach da die normale Satzkonstruktion beizubehalten
Die Patientin berichtet über
Und die Fragen nach sowieso wurden verneint
Was weiß ich, vor dem Anfall sind ihr folgende Besonderheiten aufgefallen
Auch nach dem Anfall zeigten sich besondere Symptome
Nämlich Übelkeit, Müdigkeit und eine gewisse Nervosität
Man kann das ja so ein bisschen anmoderieren
Und dass sie sich für jeden Schritt einfach noch mal Formulierungshilfen vorbereiten
Das heißt ja nicht, dass sie dagegen gefällt sind, dass sie irgendwas wild aus der Luft formulieren müssen
Zum Beispiel haben die Prüfer hier gefragt
Was sind Ursachen für einen Krampfanfall? Wie werden Fieberkrämpfe behandelt?
Was kann man im EEG sehen? Wie lange dauert die Behandlung?
Das haben die Prüfer damals alle bei diesen Patienten hier gefragt
Das heißt, da müssen sie dann, wenn sie es nicht wissen, müssen sie sagen
Oh, da muss ich den Neurologen fragen
Oder wenn sie es eben wissen, dass sie eine gute Formulierung dafür...
Entschuldigung
Jetzt geht es nicht mehr
Wie sie die einzelnen Punkte anmoderieren
Und dann eben zur Kenntnis bringen
Okay, ich denke mal, es war wieder spannend eigentlich mit allen zusammenzuarbeiten
Vielen Dank für das engagierte Mitarbeiten
Vielen Dank für alle
Und für ihre Mühe und mit ihrer besonderen Situation
Sie sind...
Heute ist schon gut im Gegenseit zu den letzten Tagen
Ja, ich habe dann auch gleich eine Info für Sie
Nächste Woche bin ich auf dem Weg, mir neue Viren einzufangen
Ich bin also wieder eine Woche bei meinen Enkelkindern, ich bin also nicht da
Ich glaube nicht, dass es sinnvoll ist, da abends Termine zu machen
Also machen wir nach einer Woche weiter an dem Dienstag dann
Das ist der 2. und...
Nee, 21.
21.
Der 21. Genau
Ah, okay, ja, Dienstag
Gut